this is what gives me energy saying I'm
gonna do something saying putting it out
there for the world to see I mean don't
out doing it I move cost from all angles
not just in the gym but a lot of bad
stuff going on and in the country a lot
of people are struggling everybody's
struggling but I've seen since them
seeing me chase this dream it's given
them an energy and I see a new lease of
life in them he's an Irish professional
mixed martial artist during his career
he's competed as a featherweight light
weight and welterweight he's the first
fighter in UFC history to hold two
titles in different weight classes at
the same time he's Conor McGregor and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success vol 2 and as always guys if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it as
well so other people can be inspired
also when you write it down you're much
more likely to lock it in for yourself
as well enjoy
stricken Matt go back to starve your
career a man with a dream you know
training the gym day-in day-out somebody
said to you you'll have or you'll be as
successful as you are now what have you
had said back then I believe you that's
what I said because I believe if I
believed in thought I had very few
people who told me that I had a small
small small group of people that would
tell me something like that order than
that it was just me telling myself yeah
so if someone came up to me and told me
that all the way back then I'd say
you're damn right
I was thrown into a Roman trade your
plumbing didn't know anything about
plumbing I just went on that side
because culture told me that that's what
I have to do I donate for a world and
then I realized this is not what I want
to do this is not what I want to do and
what am i doing for and I walked out 18
months in maybe there was a concern
there for photos for his mother for
other we didn't know what he was going
to do to be honest with you early on
obviously didn't know what it was I
couldn't look to my mother and say hey
this Irish man Tony I'm going to follow
in his footsteps because there was no
footsteps I had I had to create my own
footsteps and follow them they were a
little unsure I forced but they they
support me and they anyway I would do
what if I said I'd do it I do it so yeah
I don't just knock them out I picked
around John yeah I said this I'm sure
you probably all thinking in your head
this guy is talking absolute dribble
he's not going to do what he says he's
going to do is are probably all sitting
there thinking that but now here we are
again and I don't what I said I was
going to do I feed off this I feed off
this I love this stuff this is what
gives me energy
saying I'm going to do something saying
putting it out there for the world to
see I mean going out and doing it
there's no better feeling in the world
than that and it's as easy as that say
what you're going to do and go and do it
when you're chasing your dream and when
you're when you're working hard chasing
something you love and I'm completely
dedicated it just it just happens you
don't know you can't really note notice
it you know even still to this day I'm
in an amazing position in my life but
I'm still I'm still walking like I'm not
I'm still looking like I'm not in this
position absolutely I'm still looking
like none of this is even you know me
yeah yeah actually it's just something I
love to do and I just keep pushing and
keep working hard I can pinpoint an
exact moment for you but yes if anything
I always felt like it was happening way
back then and now it is happening but
now I almost feel like it's not
happening I mean I know what I want to
push this to something else it is I'm
always striving to
forward so you know hard work pays I put
in a hell of a look all throughout this
build up in the fire I point out more
content than anybody more content and
Fox more content than ESPN more content
than BT sport more content and everybody
on the Maglev on my own channels you
know me and I'm more cost from all
angles not just in the gym but I'm
building this medium Brian and myself
and we pumped out the content I'm very
proud of the hell went be consistently
daily movies I was releasing you know
from from like a month ago every single
day you know I mean nobody's doing that
so I'm very proud of that and I'm very
like the wall pays hard work pays and we
put in the movie and that's that's for
them I'm sitting at the top I put it all
on the line I show up I perform and I
get the results from that so which
working the plumbing business I was
working in the plumbing business at the
time ever and it was it would have been
around that time that John and lassie I
had left the founders I left the
plumbing business how bad was that
Potomac yeah horrendous were you
actually in the trenches I mean it was
an industrial who saw be like building
this it'd be like the plumbing that
would be needed in a place like this six
o'clock in the mornin and the motorway
and I just have to walk for about an
hour to get them to get there on
motorway and then I stand on the edge of
the motorway and wait for a bloke to
drive boy so give me a lift and then the
motorway was like getting them
renovation that come so take me two
hours to get to the places out in the
country then I'd be there for ten hours
walking and I was a first-year so as the
worst of the war cinemas on the beginner
then two hours to get back in the
traffic again which is the horrible
horrible time and I was like you know
what I don't want to deal with this
managers left and then I just stopped
didn't get out of bed let me die with
many times paint me out of bed we have
fights and leisure for a good world I
never spoke I didn't really speak to
Medina you just kind of stayed away from
each other anytime anytime I come across
me God is who I become we did speak with
foot versus like a look at as out yeah a
little mean 18:17 you didn't talk to
them is another kind of awkward well not
like it wasn't whatever you know
yeah just a deep relation yeah not yes
novice but since this since this has
happened since the dream has happened
since the vision that I had has come
true and like he went through eventual
times over to G to get a cancer so you
just seeking all over and in my head of
thinking maybe maybe I don't that
because he's worried about me and
there's not what I'm going to do in all
these pipes that were having all the
time I'm talking full-on so you can come
in and push it but no not a year will go
man you're punching back oh yeah we were
going out of here Wow what did your mom
say about that it's a protective of you
yeah I mean brother is right on August
it was just he just stayed out in our
book and but why did he get to that
point toward he do that because I was
doing I was doing absolutely nothing I
was ever in trouble yeah basically felt
lousy on football I was a waiter and I I
was a waiter got that call that a lot in
our neighborhood but now like and then
and then when when I started getting
that focus and realize now I'm like I'm
gonna make this happen and then never
has happened I'm um I'm making it happen
I'm a great relationship with that like
we talk all the time
and I even see energy and I see energy
and you might like if the present times
are a lot of people around there's a lot
of bad stuff going on in the country a
lot of people are struggling
everybody's program but now since EMC me
chased extreme it's giving them an
energy and I see a new lease of life in
them and that alone spores me on even
more so it's all just a perfect storm
that's happening for me and that is why
I have this tunnel vision and gods
I'm willing to kill every single man in
my path to get that belt in or anything
to secure the future from my family's
future you know I mean that'sthat's what
I'm doing for it's hard to say but when
I was a kid I used to I always be like
one of the kids always visualized
stadiums um and like even when I play
football I kick the ball against the
wall and I've pretended X scored a goal
and I'd run off and I'd be raising my
hand and visualizing a arena full of fun
vinegar
those whom I don't as a kid out on my
own I like just running around kicking
the ball I always had these visions of
something but I just didn't know what it
was and then I suppose when I came to
this of these events and it stopped
raining and it came to an event was like
okay this is it this is what I'm going
to do and then now I'm doing my
experiences in cage Wars and all the
other promotions not just all the
promotions before that as well
it helped prepare me for $0.04
situations that you find yourself in but
you're talking even fighting in the UFC
and then fighting on a McGregor show in
the UFC is if leaps and bounds different
in exam so everything has been a
learning experience for me and I take
everything as a learning experience and
I look to grow from it I'm sure and you
know what that's why I keep growing
maybe I don't know the artist people my
understand more a young a young boy
dreaming a point on the artist jersey or
off a tree when I'm pulling on his
favorite football teams a jersey in that
crisp and little not cook you know if
this is my quest these gloves right here
it is UFC gloves enough it opposed
market force always want to put these
aren't the ladies upper I get in and do
the job honestly no one can take that
away and I was uncle auntie I don't mean
to be disrespectful but I don't care
don't look enough I don't know them
nationally don't listen to talk about
something else
just don't listen notice from talking
what if I talked about this if I talk
about unarmed combat
if I took above the human anatomy yeah I
mean the way the human body Mills then
listen
how did you miss me - laughter all my
career yeah
I've been listening to them laughs my
whole career Kevin laughing what an
Irish man when I win a case where his
works right oh hell no you serious an
Irishman and Irish might win a fight in
the UFC hell no laughs laughs all around
and there's okay you got to win there we
want to win a world title
hell no he's all talk he's all hype is a
joke laughs are all around that the
Joker then the Joker goes in winter
world soil there he wants to win a
second wall soil more louder
listen of it and omit December laughter
and to sound the delt motivates me so
I'm I'm enjoying that I see that I don't
feel no doubt or I don't feel no I don't
feel that don't apply in any of these or
the UFC bombs right now they need to
rise up right now down there I've got
this situation where people are truly
telling me like they yell at me at their
very very beginning and that's
motivating to me that's what's going to
drive me to the gym when I need to go to
the gym and to put in that work to get
that win so that's where we're at right
now
josée aldo backed out mm-hmm he's going
to fight you backed out and said it was
due to a rib injury but you've been
cleared to fight by a doctor what do you
think happens I mean the man is running
scared I can I cannot force a man who is
not willing to step in a fight I kind of
force him into the Octagon to face me
but really I cannot hold any grudge
towards him because I would not want to
face me either
[Applause]
I was going to destroy him like you're
going that you were going to destroy him
you and that was you think it was pure
fear he's the reason he backed out it it
he has been medically cleared to fight
doctors have looked at him examined him
he went and saw a gynecologist I mature
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I loved in there what
you think of our vol 2 series let me
know in the comments below also I'd love
to know what did Connor say that had the
biggest impact on you which clip
resonated the most with you and why and
what are you going to take from this
video and apply immediately somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down in the comments I'm super curious
to find out finally I would think of a
quick shout out to rhyme is roses thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the book so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon